[Musique]
merci saelle Florine de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élidé scène membre du groupe Union
centriste porte-parole du MoDem on va
évidemment parler du remanimement mais
d'abord on a appris hier soir
qu'Emmanuel Macron tiendra une
conférence de presse demain à 20h15
depuis l'Élysée qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de sa prise de parole est-ce
qu'il doit fixer un nouveau cap en tout
cas j'attends effectivement des
perspectives déjà pour pour cette année
de refixer alors il avait dit hein il il
avait annoncé ce rendez-vous euh je
pense qu'on a des sujets le Premier
ministre l'a dit nouveau Premier
ministre Gabriel hatal
important et très chaud en ce moment il
y a la question évidemment de la santé
il y a la question de de l'école au
minimum sur ces sujets des annonces puis
évidemment il y a le les sujets
internationaux aussi qui sont très
préoccupants enfin sur énormément de
questions
il est attendu le président de la
République et puis cette année c'est une
année particulière c'est une année
d'élection européenne c'est aussi
l'occasion de dresser un bilan de tout
ce qui a été fait par le gouvernement
précédent et surtout par lui notamment
les suivis les suites de la présidence
française de l'Union européenne donc
vous voyez il y a vraiment des sujets
pour nous les centristes aue is vous
citez la santé et l'école qui son
précisément les deux ministères qui
étaient des ministères de plein exercice
et qui ne le sont plus qui ont été noyés
dans des grands ministères c'est une
erreur je je pense pas moi je pense que
ce gouvernement il est resserré comme
l'avait souhaité le président et et le
souhaite j'imagine aussi le premier
ministre mais avec une architecture qui
me semble intéressante et après de
décliner avec des ministres délégués
vous savez un bon gouvernement pour pour
moi en tout cas c'est des
personnalités charismatiques qui incarne
leur sujet et leur délégation leur
domaine de compétence et je pense que
nous avons autour de cette table autour
du président de la République et de
Gabriel Atal des fortes personnalités
qui je pense a très très bon choix
d'avoir gardé Éric dupometti un bon
choix d'avoir pris pour moi Rachid Dati
mais également évidemment on viendra
après sur la question des centristes
mais
derrière il faut aussi trouver cet
équilibre avec des personnalité qui
puisse aider ces ministres dans un
certain nombre de sur un certain nombre
de sujets on a vu que sur la santé il y
a déjà annes pagunché je sais pas si
elle sera nommée qui a dit qu'elle elle
elle aimerait être en charge en tout cas
de de ces questions autour de Catherine
varein donc un bon gouvernement c'est je
vous l'ai dit des personnalités
charismatiques qui pe peuvent porter des
messages porter la politique de
l'exécutif l'incarné et derrière
évidemment un équilibre politique et ça
c'est important on va y venir juste pour
sur l'école la première polémique de ce
gouvernement elle est née d'Amélie oua
Castera la nouvelle ministre de
l'éducation nationale sur la la
justification qu'elle a apporté sur la
scolarisation de ses enfants dans le
privé disant que c'est parce qu'il y
avait un paquet d'Ur dans le public qui
n'avait pas été remplacé pour ses
enfants et du coup elle les a mis dans
le privé version qui est contredite ce
matin par par des journalistes est-ce
que euh c'est la preuve qu'elle n'est
pas à sa place et que c'est un trop
grand ministère pour elle moi je pense
qu'il y a eu euh il a peut-être là sur
ce sujet euh quelques maladresse en tout
cas dans dans l'expression moi ce ce que
je retiens surtout c'est ce qu'a dit
Gabriel Attal il y a un sujet sur les
remplacements il y a un sujet sur le
nombre d'heures euh il y a un vrai sujet
sur l'éducation Gabriel Attal a été un
ministre de l'Éducation marquant euh il
a dit qu'il était il a prouvé puisqu'il
était en déplacement dans un collège des
Yvelines sur ce sujet lors de sa
première sortie et il a dit que ça
restait une de ses priorités et c'est
important de le noter alors après les
polémiques vous savez il y en a sur tous
les sujets vous le savez très bien et
d'ailleurs vous ne vous y prtez pas
forcément moi je crois qu'après ce qui
compte et c'est ce qu'a dit Gabriel
hatal c'est l'action l'action l'action
il l'a prouvé au ministère de
l'éducation national et je n'ai aucun
doute qu'il continuera à le prouver sur
les équilibres justement 14 ont été
annoncé pour le moment on attend une
deuxième salle dans les jours à venir il
y a h ministres de droite un seul modem
Marc fen est-ce que c'est un
gouvernement qui penche trop à droite
est-ce que le modem est
délaissé je je reprendrai la la la
parole de Jean-Louis bourlange hier il
dit le compte n'est pas c'est clair le
compte n'est pas pour pour le parti et
pour notre parti pour le modem ça c'est
une évidence je suis ravie que Marc fen
évidemment puisse garder ce ministère
qui est un très beau ministère et pour
le coup qui sur lequel il a engagé un
certain nombre de de travail et
d'actions qu'il faut pouvoir continuer
il y a une loi qui arrive d'ailleurs
agricul sur l'agriculture et qui va
pouvoir défendre très prochainement mais
il faut retrouver un équilibre euh dans
les ministre et dans la suite qui sera
proposée on a évidemment Jean-Noël
barreot on avait Philippe Vigier on
avait Sarah Herry on nous avions quatre
ministres dans le précédent gouvernement
au minimum il faut retrouver cet
équilibre politique bah écoutez après
c'est des questions de personnalité
comme je vous l'ai dit d'incarnation de
charisme et d'être capable de porter et
d'incarner ses politiques pour répondre
aux attentes des Français et pour être
dans l'action voilà ce qui est la
feuille de route minimum qui a été
annoncée par le Premier ministre vous
avez été contacté vous non vous
souhaitez rentrer dans ce gouvernement
non moi je moi je sais très bien où suis
est-ce que quand même il y aura un avant
et un après euh nomination du
gouvernement de Gabriel hatal dans les
relations entre le modem et Renaissance
entre le modem et Emmanuel Macron
on est des partenaires loyaux depuis le
début depuis 2017 on a réussi à
s'affirmer j'étais député pendant une
mandature on était on a travaillé main
dans la main on faisait la majorité sous
la précédente mandature là il y a plus
de
50 députés est-ce que vous serez
toujours aussi loyaux ou est-ce que vous
serez plus libre que loyux la question
elle est pas là la question elle est de
trouver des majorités pour faire passer
des textes si on par
de la feuille de route du gouvernement
et ensuite de l'équilibre politique tout
ça c'est pourquoi c'est pour je vous
l'ai dit incarner et porter une
politique et être dans l'action mais
également pour avoir des majorités pour
faire passer les projets et ça c'est
important il y a plus de 50 députés
modem il faut que ces 50 puissent se
retrouver également dans la composition
du gouvernement c'est ça que qu'on veut
dire on a on est Loyau on travaille on
fait des propositions la question
également de ce gouvernement c'est
d'être dans un travail comme on dit de
coconstruction avec les parlementaires
c'est pas qu'un grand mot c'est pas que
des paroles je n'ai pas de doute et et
je vous le dis encore sincèrement que
Gabriel hatal et les différents
ministres nommés et cette feuille de
route et j'espère que le Président de la
République nous le dira ce soir de
construire cette politique ensemble avec
cette majorité qui certes est relative
mais qui doit être associée aux travaux
il y a les européennes qui arrive dans 5
mois maintenant est-ce que si la
composition finale du gouvernement Atal
ne convient pas au MoDem le modem
présentera une liste séparée aux
européennes une liste autonome j'ai
entendu parler effectivement de de de
cette question de de liste en tout cas
ce qui se joue pour les européenne il
n'y a aucun doute que nous partageons
avec le président de la République sur
le fond les valeurs le principe la
politique qui a été nommé sur le plan
européen maintenant arrive la question
des compositions d'
aux européennes et de qui va l'incarner
donc de la tête de liste et donc ce que
nous souhaitons et ce que je souhaite
c'est que il y ait une discussion entre
Marc fenau François baayrou la direction
exécutive du MoDem et les partenaires
que sont Renaissance horizon pour le
moment avec Édouard Philippe que que
nous nous mettions d'accord et peut-être
bien plus largement ce que je souhaite
évidemment que c s'étend et notamment à
l'UDI pour travailler ensemble et
composer cette ça commence par se mettre
d'accord et donc discuter sur la tête de
Nice c'est la meilleure incarnation
est-ce que vous demandez une tête de
lice modem ah je je je je pense qu'il
faut trouver la meilleure personnalité
possible je par laquelle puis que
Stéphan séjourné était pressenti il a
été nommé au Koré quelle est à l'heure
actuelle la meilleure tête de l'IST j'ai
pas de de de de décision moi pour moi la
la bonne
personnalité je l'avais dit d'ailleurs
dès le mois de décembre c'était Gabriel
Atal vous voyez il est premier ministre
il va il va faire et il va faire
campagne évidemment sur ce sujet je
pense que on a des person nom devérant
de Clément bon ccune ce sont ce sera il
a des noms qui circulent moi je me
prononcerai pas à ce stade puisque ça
fait partie des discussions que doit
avoir l'exécutif de notre parti les
discussions ont commencé il faut faire
de la place à tout le monde et il faut
se mettre d'accord on verra au mois de
janvier le Sénat reprend ses travaux
cette semaine alors que le discours de
politique générale de Gabriel hatal est
attendu dans les prochains jours quels
sont les texes au programme des
sénateurs on voit ça avec Alex
[Musique]
poussa bonjour Alex bonjour Arian
bonjour Isabelle Floren Alex l'année
2023 avait fini sur les chapeau de rou
au Sénat avec le projet de loi
immigration le début 2024 s'annonce un
peu plus calme oui reprise des débats
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat cette semaine
avec mercredi l'examen d'une proposition
de résolution portée par Bruno rotao le
président du groupe LR au Sénat une
résolution qui comp condamne l'offensive
de l'Azerbaïdjan au haut carabach une
région peuplée par des Arméniens Bruno
rotayo appelle à des sanctions
internationales contre l'Azerbaïjan et
demande la garantie du droit des
Arméniens à revenir au haut cararabach
la semaine prochaine les sénateurs
examineront une proposition de loi des
républicains prévoyant des mesures de
sûreté pour les personnes condamnées
pour terrorisme mais qui ont purgé leur
peine de prison et qui sont considérés
comme dangereux c'est un texte qui fait
suite à l'attentat au couteau à la
tourfel en D deembre dernier par un
terroriste qui était sorti de prison et
puis fin janvier le Sénat examinera un
texte soutenu par le gouvernement une
proposition de loi pour le Bien Vieillir
qui prévoit des mesures pour accompagner
la perte d'autonomie des personnes âgées
mieux signaler les maltraitances et
mieux rémunérer le travail des aides à
domicile et Alex le Sénat va aussi
poursuivre sa mission de contrôle avec
les commissions d'enquête et des
missions d'information oui à ce mois-ci
le Sénat va lancer d'abord une
commission d'enquête sur le groupe Total
énergie une commission d'enquête à
l'initiative des sénateurs écologistes
elle sera pilotée par Yannick jado et
l'objectif c'est je cite de faire la
lumière sur le non respect des
engagements climatiques du groupe
pétrolier pouvant alimenter des
situations de corruption une autre
commission d'enquête portera sur la
production la consommation et le prix de
l'électricité en France elle est à
l'initiative des sénateurs centristes et
puis alors que le patcalis a été touché
par de nouvelles inondations en janvier
les sénateurs s'apprêtent à lancer une
mission d'information sur les
inondations en France afin de mieux
armer les territoires face à ce
phénomène récurrent et puis les
sénateurs suivront de près le parcours
de certaines lois importantes oui et
d'abord de la loi immigration son
parcours n'est pas fini le Conseil
constitutionnel va rendre son avis d'ici
le 25 janvier sur ce texte adopté au
Parlement le mois dernier la gauche du
Sénat espère qu'une partie de la loi
immigration sera déclaré
inconstitutionnel le gouvernement a
aussi on le rappelle promis à la droite
du Sénat une réforme de l'aide médical
d'État et puis la Haute Assemblée attend
également la présentation courant
février du projet de loi sur la fin de
vie qui prévoit la création d'une aide
active à mourir et le 4 mars sénateurs
et députés seront réunis en congrès à
Versailles pour se prononcer sur
l'introduction du droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans la
Constitution Isabelle foren il y a un
une autre échéance importante dans ce
mois de janvier pour les parlementaires
notamment pour les sénateurs c'est le
discours de politique générale du
nouveau Premier ministre tout d'abord
est-ce que vous savez quand est-ce qu'il
aura lieu et puis quel message doit
envoyer selon vous Gabriel Atal alors je
ne connais pas la date hein je suis pas
dans informé bah je vous l'ai dit je
pense que il y a des des sujets
importants sur lesquels les Français
attendent des actions et le Premier
ministre a dit il a dit dans sa première
intervention télévisée il a dit action
action action vous voyez bien dans les
su suffit le mot action dans les sujets
que vous avez énuméré vous avez parlé
des
inondations il y a des attentes il y a
des attentes d'action il y a on a les
Français ont l'impression souvent et en
tout cas les élus locaux he ils nous le
disent suffisamment que un certain
nombre de barrières administratives font
que il y a de la lenteur par rapport à
des sujets qui sont dans l'urgence donc
là là-dessus euh on a une demande des
Français qui est tout à fait légitime
qui est d'avoir un gouvernement et
d'avoir des ministres capables et le et
le président de la République l'a dit
lui-même il a dit soyez pas des
gestionnaires soyez des révolutionnaires
moi je pense qu'il a raison son ça
c'était sa feuille de route en 2017 hein
président son livre et moi j'étais
absolument convaincu qu'il fallait
effectivement que les politiques si vous
voulez que les ministres soient des
politiques qui reprennent les choses en
main et qui donnent la feuill de route
aux administrations vous voyez et pas
l'inverse pas se dictter donc les élu
derrière parce que nous on est quand
même des sénateurs et et on est au
service de de ce travail sur les TER
territoire ce qu'ils attendent c'est
qu'on puisse prendre des décisions sur
un certain nombre de sujets que ça soit
sur les questions d'aménagement du
territoire il il y a des lois qui posent
quand même problème sur je parle que
juste sur
l'artificialisation des sols on en a
entendu parler pendant toute la campagne
des sénatoriales la question éducative
effectivement on a vu que Premier
ministre ancien ministre de l'éducation
était au travail donc moi je le redis
sur les questions qui touchent les
Français au quotidien il y a une vraie
demande je ne doute pas que Gabriel
Attal a ça en tête Alex sur
l'immigration oui il y a eu des
manifestations ce weekend demandant le
retrait de cette loi immigration d'ici
le 25 janvier le Conseil constitutionnel
va se prononcer sur ce texte sur sa
constitutionnalité sur quel point vous
craignez qu'il y ait une censure de
cette loi immigration alors moi je dis
d'abord j'ai j'étais au travail sur la
loi immigration pour mon groupe et pour
le groupe Union centriste avec FIB
boncer comme rapporteur que nous avons
voté cette loi que nous l'avons amendé
dès la Commission et ensuite en séance
que c'est le texte du Sénat
effectivement qui était le texte de
discussion ensuite lors de la commission
mixte paritaire auquelle j'ai assisté
nous avions émis nous avions trouvé un
accord sur des points important
notamment sur la régularisation sur les
métiers en tension permettre à des gens
qui travaillent depuis un certain nombre
d'années en France d'être régulariser
c'est important on en avait besoin on
est arrivé à un accord avec Hervé
Marseille et Bruno retaillot sur ce
sujet maintenant on avait émis des
réserves d'abord la question de la me a
été supprimée et ça c'est une bonne
chose parce que on prévoit un texte sur
ce sujet il faudra s'atteler à à ce
travail mais c'était un cavalier comme
on dit devait pas faire partir ce nous
avions émis des réserves sur la question
du versement des prestations sociales
avec des durées de
temps comment demandé alors les
républicains avaient souhaité 5 ans
notamment sur la question des aPL sur la
question question des prestations qu'on
dit non
contributives là-dessus le
compromis je ne sais pas si le texte de
la CMP passe et franchira la barrière
constitutionnelle on a quelques doutes
je je ne suis pas en mesure de me
substituer au juges sur ce sujet pour le
reste ce texte est un texte important le
président de la République l'a redit au
mois de décembre c'est un texte
important parce que nous l'avons voté
parce qu'il permet aussi de la fermeté
sur des personnes qui n'ont rien à faire
sur notre territoire et qui permet les
expulsions que nous ne pouvions pas
faire jusqu'à présent donc ça c'est
important à l'image de ce qui se fait
dans un certain nombre de pays européens
et si ces durcissements sur les
prestations sociales pour les étrangers
sont retoqués par le Conseil
constitutionnel des mesures qui venaent
de la droite si elles sont retoquées
selon vous il ne faudra pas s'y
accrocher ce n'est pas grave on verra ce
qui est possible on verra ce que dit le
juge constitutionnel sur ces questions
on peut pas on peut pasz pas
spécifiquement moi je crois qu'il y a la
question des des des leveré des
interdictions qui est une question
fondamentale la question de
l'intégration qui est très importante et
les les les les dispositions qui ont été
voté pour permettre une meilleure
intégration un meilleur contrôle aussi
me semble importante on verra sur la
question également des étudiants et de
la caution des étudiants il y avait eu
des discussions sur ce sujet si le
Conseil constitutionnel valide ses
dispositions je souhaite que le le moins
possible de nos dispositions soit
évidemment inconstitutionnel parce que
ça voudrait dire que le législateur et
les législateurs que nous sommes ont mal
travaillé or je ne pense pas que nous
avons mal travaillé je pense qu'on a
travaillé en toute sincérité sur ce
texte et avec des gens compétents et des
sénateurs et des sénatrices qui se sont
attelés à la tâche pendant pendant tout
ce temps donc je je je crois que là ça
serait une remise en cause effectivement
de notre manière de légiférer qui serait
pas anodine un dernier-moi Alex
peut-être un dernier mot rapide sur la
fin de vie est-ce que vous demandez que
la loi sur la fin de vie soit présenter
rapidement comme l'ont demandé
d'ailleurs les signateures d'une les
signataires d'une tribune transpartisane
dans le journal La Tribune dimanche
est-ce que ça doit être une priorité
selon vous c'est un sujet le président
de la République a dit que il arriverait
on n' pas encore la loi je pense que euh
un certain nombre de personnalités
s'expriment euh moi je crois qu'il faut
prendre toujours le temps du du débat en
amont de la discussion donc je sais pas
s'il faut forcément se presser euh en
tout cas il y a des interrogations nous
sommes sollicités on reçoit des
courriers j'ai encore reçu à la fin du
mois dernier un certain nombre de
courrier concernant des maladies
terribles comme la maladie de Charco et
je crois qu'il faut que chaque
parlementaire ait le temps euh de
travailler en amont de cette loi sur ces
sujets d'en débattre au sein même de des
associations de recevoir un certain
nombre de de personnes et d'en débattre
au sein même de son de son parti c'est
ce que nous faisons au modem ce qu'on a
commencé à faire sur le sujet et puis
chacun sur ces questions ça je dirais
s'exprime avec son intime conviction et
je crois que il faut le temps en tout
cas moi je pense qu'il faut encore un
peu de temps merci Alex à tout à l'heure
à tout à l'heure on va parler de la
majorité et oui notamment des rapports
de force au sein de la majorité et du
MoDem qui demande plus de place on va
reparle de tout ça dans le club on va
voir l'actualité dans votre région
Isabelle Floren on retrouve jacqu paqu
qui est le rédacteur en chef du journal
du Grand Paris bonjour Jacques merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Jacques vous
allez nous parler d'un autre sujet le
froid SVIT encore sur le pays et sur la
région parisienne vous vouliez
interroger la sénatrice Isabelle Floren
sur le plan
grandf tout à fait euh madame Florine
vous vous le savez bon on estime 700
enfants les qui dorment dans la rue à
Paris alors alors même qu'ils sont
scolarisés euh donc je voulais savoir
sur ce constat quel regard vous portiez
sur la polémique récurrente qui chaque
hiver oppose les collectivités
territoriales en l'occurrence la mairie
de Paris et l'État sur les moyens
allouer à à l'hébergement d'urgence
est-ce qu'il faut comme le demande
annidalgo régulièrement euh
réquisitionner enfin investir plus alors
même que l'État au cours des dernières
années a augmenter hein son son budget
j'ai noté de 867 million d'euros à à 1,3
milliards d'euros entre de 2019 et 2021
sur l'hébergement d'urgence et adapté
mais est-ce qu'il faut que l'État en
fasse plus est-ce que c'est un sujet de
de de de collectivité quel regard
portez-vous sur cette question euh
bonjour monsieur paquet
euh c'est un sujet de l'état c'est un
sujet des élus locaux il a il y a une
question que doivent se poser et le
l'État et et et tous les élus et en
particulier évidemment la mère de Paris
c'est que dans ces périodesl enfin en
tout cas il y a y a il y a une question
fondamental pour moi c'est qu'on doit
laisser personnees mourir à risquer de
mourir dehors c'est ça le sujet c'est ça
le sujet de de de de mettre les gens à
l'abri quand quand il fait très froid et
de ces enfants que vous parlez et de ces
ces femmes ces hommes euh la seule
préoccupation que doit avoir l'État
comme les élus locaux de Paris et des
hautes scènes du Val de mararne qui sont
aussi concernés par ce plan c'est les
mises à l'AV trouver le maximum
d'hébergement pour mettre ces personnes
à l'abri on peut pas porter cette
responsabilité de laisser des personnes
dehors pendant ces périodes terribles
donc trouvons les solutions
ensemble s'opposer régulièrement
évidemment on a un problème
d'hébergement qui revient qui est
récurrent on a fait des efforts toutes
les collectivités depuis des années
grâce à ces plans qui existe maintenant
ont fait des efforts et mettent un
certain nombre de gymnases d'anciens
lycées de de collectivités font des
efforts dans les hautes scènes mon
département chaque année un certain
nombre de villes sont mobilisés parce
que les élus qu'est-ce que vous voulez
on est des humains on on sait qu'on on
doit faire ce travail et on peut pas
imaginer laisser ces personnes dans la
rue donc moi je dis trouvons les
solutions je je je trouve dommage si
vous voulez qu'à chaque fois cette
mairie a des problèmes avec l'État le
préfet d'Île-de-France fait son travail
je ne doute pas que les élus de la la
ville de Paris le font aussi si on
pouvait une fois de temps en temps à la
mairie de Paris trouver des accords avec
lest je sa que c'est compliqué he pour
eux mais se mettre d'accord pour
l'intérêt des franciliens et là en
l'occurrence des personnes sans logement
ça ser pasg pas duen qui a fait de la
politique je dis que c'est c'est pas un
sujet de polémique c'est un sujet
humanitaire rapidement une dernière
question ja oui est-ce que c'est un
sujet de décentralisation autrement dit
est-ce que vous pensez que la
décentralisation du logement que le
gouvernement souhaite pourrait
contribuer à à résoudre alors pas tous
les problèmes mais une partie de la
crise du logement parce que la crise du
logement très très violente dont les
hautes scènes d'ailleurs sont victimes
comme d'autres départements pour ce qui
est de leur recette fiscal mais la crise
du logement ne va pas arranger la
situation du logement social et du
logement et du logement d'urgence je je
suis effectivement persuadée depuis des
années que les élus
ont beaucoup d'atout pour décider en
matière de logement ils décident en
partie mais là voyez les dernières lois
malheureusement
recentralise cette politique du logement
notamment sur le logement social
avec finalement en laissant peu de marge
de manœuvre aux élus locaux à peine 20 %
sur les attributions de logement social
si on ne parle que du logement social
sans parler de l'hébergement d'urgence
ça ça ne va pas donc il faut évidemment
décentraliser une grande partie pas tout
mais une grande partie de la politique
du logement c'est nécessaire et c'est la
volonté en tout cas je la partage avec
Hervé Marseille président du groupe
Union centriste merci Jacques Paquier la
Une du journal du Grand Paris c'est les
Jos de Paris 2024 les entreprises encore
dans le flou c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup Jacques un mot
rapidement Isabelle Floren parce que
vous revenez d'Israël vous êtes parti
pour un voyage de 3 jours avec d'autres
parlementaires on a franchi le cap on le
disait dans le journal des 100 jours de
guerre qu'est-ce que vous retenez de
votre déplacement une grande émotion
c'était jours on y allait pour avec une
dizaine de
parlementaires en soutien évidemment
puis pour se rendre compte de la de la
situation de ce pays donc un grand
respect pour le peuple israélien tout à
fait mobilisé
uni pour faire face au massacre du 7
octobre voyez moi je suis revenu avec la
plaque qui m'a été remis par un soldats
israéliens des jeunes soldats tous très
mobilisés bring them home voilà pour
penser tous les jours j à ces 136 otages
qui restent toujours dans les dans les
tunnels à Gaza don trois Français un
enfant un bébé encore les rencontres
avec ses familles d'otage éprouvante la
rencontre avec Tomer un jeune rescapé du
festival Nova 23 ans qui a eu pour lui
la chance de pouvoir courir d'avoir un
père militaire qui l'a soutenu dans sa
course et qui nous a raconté avec avec
beaucoup de de sensibilité et aussi de
résilience et sans haine son épopé comme
celle de son grand-père qui s'était
échappé d'un d'un train qui menait au
camp de la mort voyez l'histoire pour le
peuple juice se répète et c'est ça le
drame donc nous voulions en tout cas
témoigner puis je vous remercie de me
laisser la possibilité de de m'exprimer
ce matin et et d'y penser et de penser à
toutes ces personnes qui sont encore
emprisonné merci de nous en avoir parlé
merci Isabelle flur merci d'être venu
pendant cette première demi-heure